hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play and nisha
machine for pigs thank you hint I know
how to sprint but you're not letting me
do it now okay alright there we go okay
what have we got here daddy says we're
not allowed to play with the animals
anymore
we were playing hide and seek with cook
and he came and shouted at us just as we
were going to hide from Miss bine mr.
grumpy teddy cook says it's because of
the guns in there but he always lets us
help polish them so it can't be that
anywhere that room is haunted if you
sneak around there at night you can hear
the ghosts in the walls behind the cases
they are often angry or that's how it
sounds we think that's why you can hear
them rattling their chains and slamming
doors and things like that we don't like
it in there anyway that might be your
dad creeping behind the paintings
watching everything you do and then
screaming and ranting and raving cuz
he's kind of crazy I'm just gonna go out
I don't think you're real or if you want
okay you're real you're as real as you
wanna beat be real what have we got in
the journal that voice on the telephone
he speaks as if he knows me and indeed I
seem to remember him like a twin pulled
away from the other at birth I feel we
are entwined though I cannot conceive of
how I am a drowning man grasping for the
surface within my own health house
beneath me I know there are splendid
architectures hidden in the dark if only
I could find the entrances so what kind
of house is this no I don't think so
something's going on here and I don't
like it at all I'm the same I did man
you you look would you look awesome -
[ __ ] you guys able to picked up
something nothing I do understand what
you've been through a lesser man would
have crumbled get you and made all this
right factory your charities it is
wonder for one melon leg we'll all be
made oh hello
wait am I hit a drink wait this is
outside what is going on here whoa whoa
what was that wait a minute what the
hell I'm going back inside thank you
very much
what the hell is going on here I'm a
visit I am tap a visitor okay there's
gonna be a lot of reading in this so
sorry if this takes a while this
distinguished professor aims to come to
ascertain my mental well-being after a
prolonged absence from the club
but I am NOT stupid he's here to spy for
them when they stalk the Ripper he was
often called to pontificate upon
lacerations and missing organs and now
he comes to me the Duff and wheedle and
my dear certain but you must still
grieve and perhaps just a quick look at
your engines to triumph of the age he
knows nothing of loss nothing of
sacrifice but two reviews that would
simply poke the hornet's nest invite a
swarm of interlopers and thieves
I must entertain this buffoon and submit
to his intrusion
perhaps I should show him the try pari
see whether his stomach so trained by
rummaging in the innards of clumsily
vivisected [ __ ] is strong enough to
stare into the real engines of his
Golden Age I may even introducing the
jack
or his sons at least we have stronger
locks on the windows now and we bring
the toys to them ha ha how dastardly
menacing ok that's locked up another
bathroom eh
somebody spying on markiplier how dare
you how dare you ok my journal and after
the party she took my arm and said but
darling how ever did you get the from
the trophy room to the guest bathroom so
quickly everyone considers you quite the
magician my darling lilibeth my father's
houses many rooms and ask for mine well
it also has its secret chambers you mean
ways to spy on the naked like this click
like
hot damn wow that is some blood methinks
you had a kill room back here why is
there so much blood oh look a valve to
some sort of machine only we had another
pig mask tada
what did I just do and I'm actually kind
of grateful it seems
hello okay what to what happened what
did I just do
I don't know but there seems to be a
walkway that I can't go down right now
okay but there is definitely a lot of
blood it's a good okay what about here
oh oh
I could put a pig into there haha oh
good I get to feed the Machine this is
my favorite is good stuff why why cause
only Bob I shall remove it
hands are bleeding raw I scrub and scrub
but the smell will not lift how can I
hold my children with these hands now
how can I kiss them good night with lips
that have issued such instruction I
don't know man
take some sleeping pills or something oh
oh she comes a snuffling by ridin by
night round a door with a pretty apron
right down to the hoof and a ringlets
are fair in her eyes China blue lay a
half-buried hand in the wintery snow you
like a hand in the wintery snow okay
this seems to be just a poem
so repos out if you want to read that I
know that some people would like my
lyrical voice to read everything to
their heart's desire but I do have to
keep moving forward for the sake of the
story alright so I saw something moved
down here you cannot tell me I did not
because I did I'm going out here let's
see what's out here can I run away
forever
is this all still my house that is the
question
hello oh hi seems to be uh some sort of
animal collection what kind of family
did this guy have bunch of way to rich
people nothing to spell really there are
way too many allusions to pigs
I remember seeing a screenshot of you
how are you doing friend you seem rather
dead why can I move this can I tip that
oh hello what if we got here how many
secret passageways does this guy have
damn I must be big just beginning lucky
finding him
what the hell ah this is the other side
of the machine that I just activated so
this is the second valve which must mean
that I'm doing something right righty-ho
some sort of portcullis just opened up I
still can't get to there though it looks
like there's a center door that I'm
supposed to go down don't know where it
is all right ha ha ha that's why I think
of that I got out okay yeah okay
oh [ __ ] you oh oh [ __ ] you okay that
door is staying closed forever where
does it why why why why
people are clapping at that what the
hell was going on here wait a minute
someone just got an arm ripped off or
something and then everyone was
applauding what the hell what is going
on oh my god can I open a drawer or
something I don't have any tinderboxes I
don't even know if there are tender
boxes in there you piano bastard don't
do nothing don't do nothing you frigging
pig masks some sort of a masquerade for
the Damned going on in this place
okay so this just looped around to the
other hallway which just means that I
need to find the central chamber in
order to be able to go down the place
where I open them I don't know what I'm
supposed to be doing
everybody hush I show pretty face this
must be it oh you mother number madness
do you know are you me who you one of my
children trapped rendus Harvey Louis
well the machine is found in his
breached is flooded the bulkheads are
down that children are engaged if you
help me I can help you release them
restore the power madness drain the
flooding and to restart the great
engines where should I go hello hello
hello hello okay yeah shits going down
over here for one I don't think these
kids are alive I know
I will cry all the way no no don't do
that we'll have none oh my god little
piggy no no little peo home that was I
will go to market there's so many
references to pigs it's not funny
no ah you're not real you're not Frick
fracking real you none kini metal
ticking as it cools and contracts this
must be the strange machine my new
friend told me of if my children
discover this place it is entirely
conceivable they strayed downstairs
delighted in their discovery very well
it seems my route is predestined the
descent begins
is it a dark descent stage identity
darkness okay whatever God these
freaking pig masks and so many so many
references wait about it right why is it
going outside that's for what well what
was the point of that I'm outside now
okay alright then whatever hop in the
back hop out the back okay don't go in
there it's bad news okay that doesn't
open as well it seems to be some sort of
some sort of locomotive device hmm can I
pilot this strange contraption new I
cannot so uh what the hell oh yeah you
mean a rock
okay okay now ah dammit I knew there's
gonna be a trap and a feeling then I had
that other feeling that you get when you
land on your ass and your legs go inside
of you bad feeling against the rising
waters curled into his cabin he barely
noticed the passing weeks the swell
nearly sunk er but his fever kept it
afloat in the dark his song glowing okay
no no a few have yo oh boy I'm in the
darkness and my lantern as not as bright
as it was before
little piggy no no little piggy go home
that is not a pig mask I realize now
that my fear of dirt stems from the
disease I contracted climbing those lost
jungle temples it is as if those clean
places so free of humanity's filth
imprinted upon my soul and left it
fragile to what I find here fear is what
keeps us all in our places and the fear
of the flesh the ruin of the flesh is
greatest of them all I am sickened I am
ruined but I will build such machines to
contain this plague and heal us all a
new century is upon us okay so what
about that did somebody bring a plague
back from those temples in Mexico that
you were mentioning what's a slowcoach
who call me names was it a trick that
voice on the phone who seemed so close
to me I aha who seems to know me so well
does he lead me for a nefarious purpose
of his own secret devising but do I have
a choice even though his motives are
unknown to me I must find my boys I will
follow the machinery down to the very
core of the earth if it will lead me to
find Edwin and Enoch once again I don't
think they're loud think they're pretty
myself [ __ ] you
the shaking ground you feel is our
attempts to clear the flood walls yeah
treachery madness we were undone yeah
children trapped by this act you were
surviving them before it is too late
oh yes do how can I find always deep
Amanda's through the piston lumen into
the tunnels then find the bilge and
flush the rotten water I will help you
where I can but you must be swift mother
new friend
hey hi we called little alright last
time I checked Wow they called me
mussels markiplier well they don't but
they will now Bing okay what is this
this seems kind of important
what is this is a fuse looks kind of
like a fuse hang on is this for
something is this important there's
another one over there
okay I'll put it up what did i do what
did I do wrong
where have I gone wrong in my life
probably something a roof how long was
that rolling for before I noticed it
haha okay all of you need to shut the
hell the hell up get the [ __ ] out go
away
I still don't know if this thing I'm
carrying is important at all
aha yeah I know is a fuse I thought it
looked like a few stick it in I don't
even need this thing Kurt chunk lot of
DA genius
hey I want to get into there let me in
close it
what was that I heard something why is
that swinging okay I think that was
supposed to swing
cuz I didn't need to go far but maybe I
need another one up later there's a lot
of these things so I'm gonna assume that
I need more of them one no man what kind
of machine did this guy build there just
seems to be an endless series of
machines going everywhere I have no idea
what is going on like did he build all
this by himself I imagine not
I don't even know that turned on but it
did something okay into the darkness I
go I guess ok what the hell was that
supposed to be bandaged feet eyes small
bones in the orchard I have carried this
world on my back with its legs about me
uh-huh
damn this wretched soul I am given birth
to nothing but machinery is that really
so bad how many demons are born of
machinery
don't be crying I don't want to hear
none of it your chunk okay that one
doesn't even need a new fuse but I did
something I don't know why okay
something over here this is something
that I need I heard that you can't tell
me I didn't hear that also I want to say
one other thing I'm playing this with
obviously volume way up but another
thing that I doing now that I don't
often do because it's hard to record is
I'm playing this on full screen at
higher resolution so
it's pretty awesome hello my little
friend okay
you need to stop with that stop with the
random boo boomys boomys are getting my
heart can't take it okay I need to flip
one more switch there might have been
something over those right if I go up
and over back the way I came there might
be something up there I'm not sure it
doesn't seem like there's anything else
over here so I will be back maybe okay
so I went up here and I do believe there
might be something over here
wait a minute yeah something I need to
get that portcullis open but I don't
know where I don't recall there being
another machine over here because this
is where I came from there go there must
be another machine forward of the
position that I was previously at not
entirely sure okay this is one machine
this is still barred up I believe anyway
is there any way that I can fiddle that
no okay
yeah I believe this didn't lead anywhere
right no this was just this thing okay
so there must be something else but I am
all out of time for this part so this
game is just absolutely phenomenal
there's been nothing that comes close to
just the ingrained atmosphere of amnesia
and this just takes it to a whole nother
level this is just this is just
phenomenal I haven't even seen a monster
yet and what I do it's gonna be ha I
don't have it always gonna be so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you
sound like you got some trouble breath
in there buddy
get some
okay I've been in everyone's like always
said